[Applaudissements]
159 milles ce nombre de spectateurs à
terre à suivre le tour de martinique des
yoles ils dépensent en moyenne 34 euros
50 par étapes principalement en
restauration
ce qui représente 5,5 millions d'euros
dépensés en mer 1,2 millions sont
dépensés par les 40 catamarans
officiellement louis il recensait en
résumé le tour des yoles pèse environ
10,2 millions d'euros
cette étude a été réalisée par le centre
de droit et d'économie du sport en
partenariat avec l'université des
antilles
l'accent a aussi été mis sur la
fragilité du budget du toril est
d'environ 800 mille euros mais très
dépendant des subventions des pouvoirs
publics dans un contexte où les
collectivités territoriales ont de moins
en moins d'argent parce que la dotation
globale de fonctionnement qui les
financent assez majoritairement est en
stagnation voire en régression
c'est une faiblesse de l'événement que
de trop dépendre finalement de ces
subventions publiques
parce que si demain le robinet se ferme
l'événement la pérennité de même de cet
événement très fort du patrimoine
sportif martiniquais pourrait être
remise en cause
trois cent cinquante mille euros sont
investis chaque année par martinique la
première pour la diffusion du tour de
martinique des yoles
c'est dire l'importance de cette
manifestation pour la chaîne publique
qui viennent démarche identitaire il ya
un ancrage très fort à cette opération à
cette manifestation sportive et
patrimoniale nous y sommes encore cette
année avec au moins quatre heures de
direct chaque jour en télévision une
présence en radio en continu sur le
numérique également beaucoup de faits
concrets depuis cette année nous aurons
l'innovation technologique qui permettra
au téléspectateur aux spectateurs de
suivre
uriel préférées chaque jour pendant ses
directs pour améliorer le produit le
rendre plus attractif mais aussi éviter
que la marque tout de martinique des
yoles ne soit utilisé à toutes les
sauces
il faut lutter contre le marketing
sauvage pour déployer de nouvelles
ressources il faut contrôler son produit
il faut donc se battre contre l'
embauche marketing retrouve
de nouvelles formes de partenariat avec
les acteurs privés parce que on a
conscience que le tour touche tout le
monde toute la population martinique et
que donc chacun veut en tirer un peu de
profit mais il y à de nouvelles formes
de partenariat à bâtir avec des sociétés
qui aujourd'hui ne sont par sponsors ne
sont pas partenaires du tome et en
bénéficient quand même un tour des yoles
qui est aujourd'hui en pleine mutation
et cette étude aujourd'hui à montrer à
tous ceux qui étaient autour de la table
que nous avons 34 ans que nous pesons
plus de 10 millions d'euros et qu'il
faille quand la fédération du rhône peau
à 40 ans qu'elle pèse plus de 20
millions d'euros
une nouvelle ère s'ouvre donc pour cette
34e édition
l'objectif faire du tour de la
martinique des yoles un véritable label